Thank you in advance.
Thank you in advance. I'm not going to
eat. Well,
Umi-kun, that's because I
originally had a reservation at the restaurant. It's a
pretty good restaurant, but it's hard to get a reservation, and I
thought it would be a waste to cancel.
But I'm not going to eat tonight.  It seems that the schedule is limited to members only.The spare
ribs and wine they serve are
exquisite, and
famous actors often come here.I wish I could have
continued to hear their impressions of the play.I'm
really sorry.Today is such an important day.  He's been
doing his best for me all this time for this day,
even while I'm doing this now.That's why I have to
go now.I love him.He's the one
Chizuru-chan likes.He's
a bit of a farewell story, and he said something that would be popular.
Stop it, he's just someone from the same university, and it's
true that we're spending more time together, but that's
only because he's making a movie, and he
seems to like her like the moon.When I
look at Chizuru-chan,
what did he do at one point?  I was depressed, but
now that I think about it, I think I regained my energy around the time I made the movie.I
thought maybe my grandma was feeling better,
but I guess it was because I was able to be positive.I like
that guy.
[Music] No matter
what I do, I
don't like it,
but I don't
like it or not.
I'm sorry, I have to go.
[Music]